i
was sitting um thinking about the
podcast this morning taking taking some
notes reading a couple of research
articles
um in this beautiful park today um and
i was listening i ended up eavesdropping
and i ended up
ultimately going over and and telling
the people that i had been we had a
wonderful conversation
um i was positioned such that i couldn't
help it over here with these three women
um you know a bit older than us you know
three women
um liberals ian or outside of portland
um white women not that it should matter
um people with adult children because i
heard them talking about them
who were engaging in this very careful
discussion of
of covet in so many ways one of them had
been diagnosed with it and gotten a
false negative first
and then come up with a false positive
but that sent everyone into some kind of
disarray like what do we you know what
are we supposed to do with this false
negative when clearly
she this person seems to have it um
to which one of the women sitting there
says you know i don't i just don't think
the tests are reliable and they're not
reliable in either direction there's
false negatives there's false positives
um and they're saying that they're not
you know they're not prepared to to
travel yet because
you know it's likely that another um
another wave is coming
um and so and um you know and they're
and they're vaccinated but they're not
they're not sure um
about everything that they're hearing
about the vaccinations and so
one of them said cnn is so untrustworthy
i don't trust them any more than i trust
fox at this point so again this is
liberals and i know a lot of people
um listening to us and watching us might
say the opposite you know fox is
becoming untrustworthy they don't
i don't trust it anymore that i trust
cnn at this point
um but i'm saying this you know speaking
to
um those many of us who are liberals
and those many um who would say oh
you're not and no liberals think the way
that you do
right this is this is anecdote for sure
um
but listening to these women talk and
then talking with them a little bit
before before i had to leave to come
back to
do this you know they're saying it's
they're talking about particular
politicians and i'm just not going to
name them here and and you know
hollywood actors and stuff and saying
they're trying to make the unvaccinated
enemy it's horrible get them they seem
to be saying
and our country is in such poor shape
and with regard to
the media and corporation and the
politicians each of those groups they
said they're just making [ __ ] up
this is what they said over and over
again they're just making [ __ ] up and
the path that we're on 100 for sure
people are going to be restricted in
terms of where they can go
it's terrifying so this is one
conversation
one that i overheard between three women
in you know very liberal portland very
liberal people
vaccinated who were saying this is
this is a very big problem for our
country and for democracy
and um effectively much like
in a totally different domain what i was
hearing in this conversation with
camille foster and barry weiss on
the honestly pod um that when the
conclusion is handed to you
and you are told there is no possible
other thing that you could conclude
you should immediately begin to wonder
what you're not being told
so um i think you're i think you're on a
very important
topic here and i'm
juggling a few things that seem to fit
together and you know this is the first
time i've heard your riff on this so i
don't know where this goes but
i want to start with um something some
some of our listeners will have heard of
and many will not
or won't know what it means even if
they've heard the term you know what a
push poll is
i do but uh it's a push-pull is a poll
whose purpose is not to collect
information but actually to drive belief
right um and so and done by uh
you know the the people working on
behalf of politicians like what under
what circumstances do push pulls
exist yeah it's it's often uh done by
workaday people who have just
you know signed up for a job but they're
uh i think always instituted by
terrible people who are using the act of
data collection
as a stalking horse for another purpose
and it's hard to imagine how any decent
person finds themselves
engaged in that behavior well but i mean
a push-pull
i wave i wish we had an example here
because
my sense is that they don't always
unless you're unless you're thinking
very carefully
they don't necessarily reveal themselves
oh right no they they
it's like any other kind of advertising
right right pr
advertising you're supposed to think
it's not working on you that's when it
works on you
right right um but anyway the idea is
there's something that we all understand
to be a legitimate exercise which is a
poll
and because it exists you can use it for
another purpose which is actually to
manipulate people's belief structures
and what you're describing your
conclusion
driven landscape is a place
where the language and form
of logic and analysis is borrowed for
something else
and i think this actually explains a lot
of what is happening it's equivalent to
scientism
right and and high x formulation but
it's it's bigger than that yeah it's
it's yeah
it's logicism analyticism
and so here's what i think you and i are
running into
you and i are trying to do an analysis
of an
uh a set of evidence that is nothing if
not
confusing and self-contradictory right
and you know on the one hand that's not
outside of what we do
on topics where there's nothing writing
right in evolutionary biology you're
often looking at
different kinds of conflicting evidence
and trying to figure out what the
underlying pattern is so you know that
sorting through evidence and figuring
out what to wait and and how
is a is an art more than a science and
if you're good at it when it comes
what it results in is predictive power
um but anyway the point is
that's just a that's just a thing that
we do
we are now doing it in a realm where
everybody perceives a great deal at
stake and there is a lot at stake
um but what that results in is a lot of
people being hostile to the exercise of
those
tools and availing themselves of the
right to borrow
logic and analysis or the trappings of
them
for the purpose of manipulating and i
think
almost to a person that the people that
we come up against
who we know who we have had positive
histories with
who are doing this imagine that where we
are
is this this is no time for analysis
right it's like the person who wants to
question authority in the middle
of trying to you know defeat the machine
gun nest right this is not the time for
that this is chain of command people
this is chain of command business and so
the point is look we all understand the
vaccines
are good and that they are the key to
going where we're going and we all
all of us adults understand that it's a
more complicated story than that
and this is no time to talk about
downsides trade-offs
risk uncertainty long-term hazards any
of those
things because the point is we either
get over some threshold number
in which case things get better or we
don't and you by trying to deploy your
analysis
in the midst of this battle are getting
in the way of us crossing that threshold
now um i will speak only for me though i
would imagine you are in the same spot
i've looked at this puzzle there's no
threshold it's not like we're going
somewhere it's not like some policy is
being
deployed that explains what number we're
shooting for and if we can only get
enough people on board we will actually
be able to relax there's no conceivable
way
that this goes that direction but and if
we were if if
even if there had been a number they're
like that's what we're shooting for 100
it'd be like catch-22 they just keep on
upping the
number of missions i think the thing is
either they're so deluded that they
think there's a number
right and they haven't looked at the
vaccines that they have at their
disposal
and what will happen if you there's no
number right there's no number to that
the vaccines are too leaky and there's
too much for the globe they can't reach
so
sorry but that's like that's a
combination of you know the social
landscape is such that actually there is
no number
and we're certain of that but the more
important thing of course
is the actual the facts on the ground
the non-social landscape the biology
is such that we actually have never
heard because there does not exist
they plan to end the pandemic with the
extant
vaccines right and so it's all done by
implication well there are vaccines and
vaccines could be used
to end a pandemic and there's some
number that you have to hit and those
people who
uh you know aren't participating are
counterproductive to that end
so it's all done through implication but
it's never stated for some reason yeah
um but in any case
i think this this neatly explains
i hope it's not too neat but i think it
neatly explains the experience of having
people who on an ordinary day
should see through the failures of our
public health apparatus
just as easily as we do who seem to be
completely blind to any level of failure
that exists there
and the basic point is they are on a
team
because they believe that we are in a
battle that has a coherent
end point and that anybody who is not
you know
shouldering their share of the load is
counterproductive rather than no
sorry that battle doesn't even exist
that's not the battle we're in
right um and so frankly i guess
you know the other term that i think
belongs
in in here is that this is basically a
machiavellian
approach to analysis that effectively
that's interesting because there is
loosely understood to be a coherent
public health
endpoint and it is imagined that
the prescriptions we have been given
with respect to what to do
must point in that direction that there
is a
sidelining of one's own self-skepticism
that is resulting in uh a kind of
certitude from people who
know better than to have that kind of
certitude about anything that they
believe
right yeah you know who who amongst our
friends
isn't good at the question of you know
where's the weak spot in my own
argument right right these people are
typically good at that and they seem to
have just lost touch with that
that instinct which i take to be um
about a i think demonstratively
demonstrably false belief that we are on
a path
and that there is something useful at
the end of it and that therefore it is
simply time
to put it all aside and pull together
well or
um i guess an alternative
way to think about where people believe
we are is that we are
um ascending you know trying to take out
a machine gun nest that we are
in the fog of war and uh that there is
someone
and they are telling us what needs to be
done and um
and ignoring the chain of command here
will get all of us killed
so stop it already right right and and
you know frankly how do you create the
sense of the fog of war without
the fog of war you have to get people
scared you have to get people back on
their heels you have to get people
um terrorized not just by a virus which
is actually terrible
and horror horrifying but also terrified
of each other
you have to create division between
between human beings
such that whenever you go out you're
looking at them going oh i'll bet
but you're the enemy right right so and
in this so two things one in this milieu
the fact that we can't seem to make the
point that hey actually we're not the
thing that you just portrayed us as
right or wrong we don't believe the
things that have been ascribed to us
that's odd that
that anybody would be continuing anybody
honorable would be continuing to assert
these things or to believe them
unless the point was really the purpose
is to get you to stop what you're doing
irrespective true false whatever
right the thing you point to though
about
um it's it's funny this uh
the fog of war is a natural fact of the
confusion of the battlefield and it has
impacts yeah if you need the fog of war
to be useful to some objective that is
unstated and i'm not claiming that
that's what our friends are up to
but i do believe that somebody is sure
uh polluting our environment so that we
are not capable of making sense
that we would otherwise make it is the
fog machine of war
the fog machine the fog machine oh boy
pr meets war yeah yeah yeah
and so that that is in fact what i think
we are really fighting over is whether
or not
this is simply a war and that fog is
natural and we need to get unconfused
and all pull in the same direction or
we are being fogged so that we will be
confused about what is and is not on the
table in terms of
paths forward so that for example the
possibility of driving
sars kobe 2 to extinction which you and
i are still advocating and still i hear
almost nobody else
talking about is even no to the degree
that most people say anything about they
say
yeah everything else may be but
certainly not that we're never going to
accomplish it at this point right
even though it seems to be implied in
the
um simplistic prescription that has been
handed to us right what then is
yeah what what then what are we trying
to achieve right
um so all right fog machine award is
i like it i mean i hate it and i like it
yeah
it's a decent it's horrible it's
clarifying yes yeah
all right
[Music]
you